the approach here is essentially
eclectic drawing upon
ethological
psychoanalytic and behaviorist theories
it attempts to explain military
ineptitude in light of five inescapable
if unfortunate features of human
psychology
these are
one
man shares with lower animals certain
powerful instincts and again these are
like the root
of what he's talking about
these five
inescapable
parts of our brains
so we share with lower animals certain
powerful instincts two unlike lower
animals most men learn to control
direct and sublimate
these instinctual energies
so
right we got control over some of these
things at least we're supposed to we can
at least frustrate them that's a good
word right we can at least frustrate
them
three
while by far the largest part of this
learning occurs in early childhood its
effects upon adult personality are
profound and long lasting again this is
where you know you get into like uh you
know freud and how you're raised and all
these little things that are in your
childhood and i don't know if that's
right or wrong i don't know if that's
right or wrong because i think i've seen
people that have been raised all kinds
of different ways and end up all kinds
of different ways
but i think the end result is you end up
with a personality regardless of where
it comes from you end up with a certain
personality or certain personal
personality aspects that we can pid we
can identify them
four residues of this early learning and
in particular unresolved conflicts
between infantile desires and the
demands
of punitive morality may remain wholly
unconscious yet provide a canker of
inexhaustible anxiety
again really tying our behaviors to what
how we got treated when we were kids and
if you got
you know
the room had to be clean you had to
clean your plate like all those little
things and again chiming if you guys
think i'm wrong i've known people that
were raised in a totally strict
environment and they end up on one end
of the spectrum and i've known people
that raised in a totally strict
environment they end up in a totally
different person
are there some root things that are
overlapping sure but i think we have to
look
and maybe it's just the way
psychologically things play out
you know but
they're there does he say unresolved
yes so i think that has i think that
word jumps out at me
the unresolved part i think
i think a lot of times people are able
to come to terms with something from
their childhood and and then
own it right move past it um i think
it's the unresolved part that lingers
right where there's still
there's a bit of broken something there
that hasn't been addressed and because
of that it continues to plague the
individual as they try to move forward
so maybe if i know you two and you both
were raised you know in this super
strict way
and yet carrie was like you know what
you know my my mom was just a little bit
crazy and that's cool and but dave was
like they couldn't let it go
maybe that's what makes dave you know a
little bit
a little bit a little bit harder in that
respect or maybe you're both raised by
you know the hippie parents that didn't
care and you know
carrie was like yeah i don't need to
care about anything it's all good and
dave was like you know i don't want to
end up like that you end up with a
more
militaristic mindset or a trauma hippie
mom wrecks the van mm-hmm
johnny
moves on you know
dave doesn't
dave
dave bears the scar right
is this thing hidden close to home to
you man what's going on here she's
bearing the scars i'm just saying
yeah
i really do i think respect the vet
all right uh the last one when this
anxiety becomes the driving force in
life's endeavors the fragile edifices of
reason and competence are placed in
jeopardy so that's scary
again
regard for me regardless of the source
of this personality trait that you end
up with
it if that be it doesn't matter where it
came from
if you have it and it becomes the
driving force in your endeavors that's
where we run into a problem and
and i don't want to say it doesn't
matter where it came from
but
regardless of what you think of that
we know someone that's
hyper their ego is out of control like
it doesn't really matter
i shouldn't say it doesn't matter where
it came from but there's nothing we can
do about where it came from but if i
understand that dave has a massive ego
i'm not sitting there going well you
know do i need to have him sit down on
the couch you know and like let's go
go go hypnotism and break down where he
got this giant ego from or might be like
okay he's got a big giant ego how do i
work through this how do i get this you
know how do i approach him with ideas so
we can we can dwell on that a little bit
where these people how these people end
up like this and i think that is
important to an extent is just if you
can understand somebody a little bit
better you can maneuver better
um
but regardless they end up you end up
with these personalities
different personalities
i knew a guy
um
i mean i know you know there was a whole
slew
because when i got in the navy so it's
1990 this had to be similar for you
there's a whole slew of my friends in
the seal teams who parents were just
straight hippies
just freaking hippies
like conceived at woodstock and whatever
like
just straight-up hippies and
yet they took the most militaristic life
that they could
being a commando right so
how's that work
yeah
maybe it's a reaction to that you know
and vice versa have you ever known
someone that had that hardcore strict
religious upbringing and how do they end
up wild freaking maniac
you know i feel like that's the generic
go-to right where it's like the rebel
you know
came from that strict catholic school
you know whatever they just go the other
way and it's weird because you that's
not neither one of these things is like
oh you went to a strict catholic school
now you're a rebel no there's plenty of
people that went to a strict graphic
school they become strict catholics
so
that's i think this is why and again i'm
not a psychologist and i don't even know
enough about psychology but i'm saying
regardless of my opinion because that's
all it is an opinion
the result that you get is oh this
person has a very rebellious attitude
and he's in my platoon how do i deal
with him or this person has a massive
ego he's in my platoon
how do i deal with them